hi approached uh my name is Judith
Resnick I'm the Arthur Lyman professor
of law at Yale law school we the Lyman
Center along with Dwayne Betts the Lyman
Center being Jennifer Taylor shout out
here who's here there's a report about
us and if anybody wants to know more
than I wish we could we had to tell you
about solitary confinement there's a
report called time and sell just out
about more than 50 000 people in
solitary confirm in the United States
um so we Freedom reads Peter Diane
Whitney Humanities plus plus are all
very glad that you're all here I was
actually it's I was at the law school
right now there's another conference
called access and accountability
run by the uh what is called the Mafia
the medium free media Freedom of
Information clinic and I wish that all
60 of those people could be also sitting
here and I did Pitch please think about
and talk about and write about and thank
goodness you do some the state of
incarceration
um I'm going to start by introducing
some of the themes of the panel and our
discussion with a little bit of
pictorial and text while also and then
thereafter each of our panelists is
going to speak in the order in which
they're seated actually Elizabeth uh
Hinton and I'm not gonna I I think
everybody's bios are available so I'm
not going to talk about who they are
because you're going to listen to them
rather than me talk about them and uh
Echo Yannick and Zachary
Lazar sorry I was gonna there's a law
school person who has a name anyway and
Tracy Mears I was going to add alter
names but I I want to start by talking
about the degree to which incarceration
has been very visible is very visible
and has been for centuries as a practice
that it is visible to those in and
outside of Prisons for any of the many
public minds or eyes who want to look or
who care to look and not only that but
the fact of incarceration has been for a
long-term advertised as well as debated
and the practices of incarceration and
the practices of punishment are here and
I want to invite because it's a
wonderful audience to think about the
range of texts and materials that are
available so assuming there I'm in
Amsterdam in the 17
1980s the population is declining and
there is a folio which thank you the
beinecke and I also need to advertise
that there's an exhibit at the beineke
an exhibit at the law school on some
images that you can um that you can go
see and I have some handouts for that
so
um this image is one of about a hundred
in a folio put together to tell you move
to Amsterdam it's a great town 20 of the
images are about how they detain people
either in orphanages poor people and
this is the men's House of Correction
which is the largest of the buildings of
that era being built and this is the ad
this is not anything covert whatsoever
and when you go inside and thank you
Bernard hardcore because this one's in
the color the color image is fabulous
you're watching somebody being flogged
and this is the ad we keep control we're
very tidy we're neat we make you do
menial work and we whip you if you don't
behave move to Amsterdam
okay
now as of course the invention of the
penitentiary comes of course starts to
be some concerns so not all the visuals
look like this and if you go to the
British Yale Center for British art
you'll find this which is a print after
a painting by Thomas Ryder of the
captive it's the Brits are depicting
someone in a French prison get the
channel fight and
um it's pointing to this kind of saintly
chained prisoner to start the call for
reform and across the
uh continent and then across the oceans
and this is Europe and the United States
not all the World by any stretch of the
imagination
um although there's a colonial piece the
um the efforts at religious societies to
reform improve the lot of prisoners
ramps up with the founding of social
sciences of sociology and anthropology
and this thing called criminology and
the next stop is now a plaque that was
put up in 1970 but it commemorates in
1870 the first ever national
Congressional Congress where the people
who were the prison men met with
Rutherford B Hayes welcoming them as the
governor before he became president of
Ohio to say welcome to these
organizations that are committed to
figuring out how to run and reform
prisons and unlike the early part of the
1800s when we really wanted menial work
now we're into reformation and useful
work some of it of course hugely profit
making for the people who were doing it
they talked they debate you can read
I've read on hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of pages of their materials how
you punish which way you punish do you
cook do you frog and here's an example
from a British prison of 1902 and you're
looking at a disgusting practice called
what they called a tread wheel man being
made to go Circle seven steps over and
over and over again while this is all
displayed available seeable maybe for a
deterrent Jeremy Bentham wanted you all
to be scared and not do this so he
wanted the panopticon so uh this is the
1920s this is a painting of Marjorie fry
part of it is that in a world of gender
stories this gender story needs to
include that there are reformers some of
whom are women some of whom are
feminists and Fry and her colleagues of
the Howard Society Howard league in
London are the first speakers I've found
in a variety of documents that say the
word rights and torture prison is
torture and people deserve rights and
there should be an International
Convention and the guys who are by then
running the international penal
Penitentiary commission poo poo the
ladies they call them the ladies and say
get rid of them but these are incredibly
entrepreneurial smart women who go to
Geneva and Lobby the League of Nations
with these amazing anti-death penalty
Pro con and pro convention for the
rights of prisoners their words and
therefore the guys at this international
organization which is full of or of
countries that are Empires say we better
Draft rules and the women convince the
man who Draft rules and for the first
time in 1935 the League of Nations
adopts the standard minimum rules for
the treatment of prisoners which you see
are form a humanitarian point of view
and a social point of view and what
their rules are just give you heartburn
in terms of how awful prisons are so
there should be enough food I.E there
wasn't enough food there should be
enough water
Etc corporal punishment is generally not
acceptable except in exceptional cases
if a medical person authorizes it that
is because the Brits love whipping it
isn't just Amsterdam and it isn't just
elsewhere the Brits and the British
colonies have flogging birching and
whipping a lot and in exceptional cases
a dark cell if regulated by law I.E a
dungeon is also permissible as well the
Caesar rules are disseminated this is
the frontus piece from the home office
with the queen seal which tells you that
we're sending them around to everyone
and then World War II comes this
organization International Organization
actually meets in Berlin in the 1930s
because if prisoners have no rights
because the U.N did not the League of
Nations had no language of Rights then
fascist whatever your government is we
can make things together to manage the
folks we are keeping in detention but
when you get to the United Nations in
1955 although these are not enforceable
the new words come in in a world of
Rights non-discrimination and the person
has a right to self-determination and
Liberty but then there's the sad caveat
unless we need to do something to
control and manage you and if you go
through some of their rights we are now
discipline as needed we're Banning
corporal punishment there's no longer a
dark cell but here's what we tolerate we
tolerate
reduced diet as an euphemism for bread
and water and we tolerate solitary
confinement if it's certified that you
can
stand it now if of course in the United
States and elsewhere in the world in
terms of colonial imperialism of course
the word the centrality of race in this
story so there are many pioneers in the
United States in the 1960s who are
individual prisoners who believe that
law law will help them and they look at
the U.S Constitution and they say law
can help me and in doing this this is
Caleb Washington and the case is called
Washington V Lee not George Washington
versus Robert E although the people
who've styled the complaint knew exactly
what they were doing Alabama had a
statute that said segregation by race
meant that black and white people
couldn't be chained together or sleep
together in prison a lawsuit challenging
this in 1966 wins in the lower courts
and then the U.S Supreme Court
they bring what they call a statement of
questions and the question they raise
this is 1967 in the United States and
these people have the Yiddish word as
hutzpah to say does a prisoner serving a
Penitentiary sentence have a
constitutional right to question the
validity of State statutes requiring
Separation by race which is to tell you
the status of the person was claimed to
be not a person who had any relationship
to the U.S Constitution once it was you
were convicted and by the way this is
the first term that Thurgood Marshall is
sitting in the U.S Supreme Court which
is the first term it's not an all-white
institution itself so just to be quickly
summarizing first of all it's a very act
very visible activity there are debates
about permissible and impermissible and
the freaks who the people who are the
serious speakers of the claim for a
constraint on Sovereign power are the
folks who are incarcerated who say you
can't treat me like this and the answer
from Justice is black the court says yes
you can't segregate by race except comes
a concurrence if you if their racial
tensions you can take them in account to
maintain security discipline in good
order in prisons and jails that's the
Mantra maintain security discipline and
good order so here come to Arkansas in
1967 and this is a picture in the
newspaper thank goodness for newspapers
and the newspaper says this is the whip
Arkansas says to maintain good order we
whip prisoners and Winston Talley is a
guy who says in this handwritten
petition please people writing look at
the literature produced by the people
who are in detention handwriting in a
variety of ways not only to courts but
to courts included whip whipp no
evidence this is a man who's part of
I've thought of learned some about him
that he's part of a social movement but
he understands himself he says article 8
you can't whip me and he gets a hearing
in federal court this is the group of
people who are testifying as Arkansas
has about 60 percent white prisoners and
is whipping black and white people
together now of course while these
people may or may not be part of
movements there is of course a huge
social movement of which the Attica
picture is one example the Nation of
Islam is organizing in prisons as well
and there's an effort at what is
profound and serious claims that of the
capacity of the state to require the
state to not punish people in particular
ways and you get for a little while
federal judges saying here's in the
fifth circuit with Louisiana Angola we
are here the Constitution's here you're
in relationship to the Constitution
you're us as well but as is sadly
familiar to many of you by the 1980s
we're not here very much and the new
floor of what is tolerable
constitutionally is minimal civilized
measure of life's Necessities a pathetic
floor for this whole thing and here just
to bring you to date in 08 in California
you have hyper density hyper density
which every buddy there's actually the
word used to be called crowding
overcrowding is a weird word
that gets added but if you go to the
1970s and 80s they call it crowding so
overcrowding is here and anybody who
wants to look at its harms the
Department of Justice this is the
document that's out that is kind of a
trigger warning it's horrible to read
about Alabama state prisons and of
course it's appropriate to invoke them
because the prisoners have just gone on
strike there in protest you can read
pages of this so it's not secret there's
contestation about it and the question
about what is permissible in a social
order brings me to the last image which
is by faith Ringgold called the United
States of Attica marking the violence
that is incomplete the last sentence at
the bottom which is hard to read says
this map of American violence is
incomplete please write in whatever you
find lacking seems to me she is the
words to be the introduction to the
people who are coming to speak and I'm
incredibly grateful that they've come
and are here and are going to talk to us
um about the problems of this which they
they can do either standing up or
sitting depending on their backs and
their spines
go for it Elizabeth you're next whatever
you want
thank you for that and thank you to the
Whitney Humanities Center Freedom reads
the Lyman Center and of course the
organizers Judith Resnick Dwayne betz
Jenny Carroll and Peter Brooks for
inviting me to join this conversation
and all of you for coming so picking up
um on this slide this is actually like
the perfect segue I want to think about
the image of the prison in the public
mind in the era of um Rebellion what
could be seen as the kind of opening act
of mass incarcer incarceration
because immediately after the long hot
summers of the late 1960s and early
1970s people of color and black people
in particular start getting
disproportionately and systematically
locked up right and mass incarceration
as we know it begins so what I call The
Crucible period of rebellion lasted from
1964 to 1972 And every major city burned
during these eight years as well as
midsize and smaller cities and Rural
towns across the United States the east
and west from the North and South the
Rust Belt to the Sun Belt leading to
nearly 3 000 incidents in total across
more than 1 000 segregated communities
of color now nearly all of these
rebellions were sparked by a police
encounter a moment of tangibly felt
racism
yet the tens of thousands of black and
brown people who threw rocks and bottles
at police plundered local stores
detonated Molotov cocktails were
rebelling not just against police
brutality right they were rebelling
against a broader system that had
entrenched unequal conditions and
anti-black violence over Generations
so the so-called riots constituted a set
of demand for jobs first and foremost
expanded educational opportunities
better housing conditions and an end to
state-sanctioned violence these of
course were the same demands as the
civil rights movement more broadly but
policy makers treated the rebellions as
criminal acts as crime not as calls for
full economic and political inclusion in
American society
so under the banner of the war on crime
which president Lyndon Johnson started
in the spring of 1965 the federal
government supported the expansion of
police and targeted black Puerto Rican
and Mexican-American communities
accompanied by the militarization of
those police forces with an arsenal of
surplus weapons and Technologies from
Vietnam and interventions in South
America and the Caribbean so the
national solution the counter-insurgency
was more police leading to more
incarceration and the effect was to
place low-income families and their
communities of um under the omnipresent
gaze of police and to normalize
confinement now we often think of police
brutality as being the proximate cause
of the collective violence as was the
response most recently to the brutal
murders of George Floyd and Brianna
Taylor which sparked the non-violent and
violent protests that we witnessed
during the summer of 2020 but the
rebellions very often began um in
response to the Specter of incarceration
people thought back when police
exercised their most basic legal
Authority making arrests according to
data calculated by the political
scientist Christian Davenport at the
University of Michigan's radical
information project about 24 of the
rebellions during The Crucible period
began in response to an arrest or an
attempted arrest that was seen in the
minds of participants as arbitrary
the Watts rebellion of 1965 and Newark
in 1967 which along with Detroit of
course are kind of the iconic Riots of
the era in the public imagination each
began in response to the arrest of a
black motorist people did not want to
see their friends family and fellow
community members handcuffed detained
captured removed from the community
thrown Behind Bars and possibly sent too
far away prison
in Baltimore black residents challenged
officers arresting Authority with
determination disrupting arrests on
three separate occasions in late June
1968 about two months after the
week-long Rebellion that followed the
assassination of Martin Luther King
on June 19th after an officer tried to
arrest a young man in the heart of the
black Upton neighborhood in front of a
growing crowd a woman scratched him down
his left arm and took his watch the
officer sprayed the woman and others
with mace and the people who gathered at
the scene left
less than a week later a 15 year old boy
grabbed an officer's arm during a
disorderly conduct arrest giving his
suspect an opportunity to flee the
officer hit the boy and took him into
custody
the next evening two dozen teenagers
began shouting at officers Paul
karasavic and Norman stamp as they
attempted to arrest three people on
burglar burglary charges at around 11 30
in the reservoir Hill Neighborhood
a 13 year old girl jumped on stamps back
forcing him to let go of two of the
suspects and the men escaped so officer
stamp sees the girl who kicked him
clawed him and bit him
eventually stamp managed to put the girl
in handcuffs for resisting arrest but
suddenly her 14 year old brother
attacked the officer from behind
and after a struggle the brother was
also detained another 14 year old boy
helped free the third burglary suspect
by assaulting karasavic the suspects all
three of them young men escaped and the
kids who came to their defense went to
jail
viewing the arrests as an injustice and
the potential to be incarcerated as an
injustice these young people were
willing to take justice into their own
hands and sacrifice their own freedom in
the process
although the informal arrest prevention
campaign in Baltimore did not directly
inspire a broad rebellion in other
cities a single arrest could lead to
sustained Collective violence committed
by hundreds of people for example in
Jersey City in August 1970 about 500
black and Puerto Rican residents
declared what police called open Warfare
on whites in the downtown area after two
patrolmen stopped a vehicle for a minor
traffic violation weeks later in nearby
Hoboken a six-hour long drug raid during
which 25 people were arrested caused a
two-night rebellion The prominent 21
year old activist Luis Lopez came to the
protest came to protest the mass arrest
and was subsequently arrested himself
for interfering with police duties and
using obscene language
by 7 30 PM 300 to 400 enraged Puerto
Ricans as the Hudson post dispatch
described them surrounded City Hall
demanding Lopez's release about 30
people sat at the intersection of
Washington and first to block traffic
the crowd threw rocks and bottles at
police and smashed windows in the area
Lopez continued to protect to protest
the arrest of Puerto Rican residents in
Hoboken leading to another Rebellion a
year later it started with an angry
confrontation between Luis and Jaime
Santana age 26 and 24 and A store owner
whom the brothers claimed to repossess
their television set under false
pretenses after the Santana brothers
were arrested for assault with a
dangerous weapon Lopez led a small group
of activists to Police Headquarters to
demand the release of the prisoners and
to request the suspension of the two
officers who allegedly used brutal force
during the arrest
soon after Lopez and his group left
police reportedly received calls that
people were harassing motorists and
passers-by outside of city hall and then
when local officers arrived a group of
about 300 people began throwing cans
bottles and Bricks at them and the
Rebellion spread from there
seen as an unfair unjust and racist
institution the siblings in Baltimore
Louise Lopez and his Defenders and their
counterparts in other cities took the
act of policing and the resulting
incarceration as a form of State
violence that could only be contested
with further violence
the beginning of mass incarceration
helped bring The Crucible period of
rebellion the period of frequent
community-based instinctive violence to
an end the systematic imprisonment of
young people of color that started in
this era effectively removed from cities
a significant portion of the young
people who had committed and sustained
the political violence as such by the
mid-1970s 75 percent of black people in
American prisons were under the age of
30.
although black Americans have been
disproportionately incarcerated since
the Civil War until the 1970s they
amounted to about a third of the
nation's prison population this changed
in the mid-1970s when black Puerto Rican
and Central and South American groups
began to approach majorities and state
and federal prisons
the mass incarceration of black and
brown Americans over the past half
century can be partly attributed to the
socioeconomic conditions that lay at the
root of the rebellions and that became
even worse as the decade wore on with
the end of the war on poverty and the
simultaneous escalation of the war on
crime
the fires in Miami in 1980 in Los
Angeles in 1992 of course nationally
televised moments of mass political
violence that reached a truly
unprecedented scale are legacies of the
historical trends that began in the late
1960s and at the dawn of mass
incarceration
in both cases people did not erupt in
response to a specific incident of
police brutality but instead to groups
of police officers who were acquitted
despite undeniable evidence of abuse in
the LA case the 89 second video of
officers striking Rodney King with their
feet and their billy clubs between 53
and 56 times which of course was the
first viral video of police brutality
and the proof of police brutality and in
the white public imagination right did
not move the jury in Simi Valley to
convict
by the time La exploded the prison
population had exploded more than
five-fold from fewer than 200 000 people
in 1970 to 1.1 million in 1990 and it
would continue to explode during the
Clinton Administration with the 94 crime
Bill cement in the United States as the
country defined in part at least by mass
incarceration
the violence in Cincinnati in 2001
Ferguson Baltimore and a handful of
other cities during the Obama years and
in the summer of 2020 occurred in
reaction to exceptional incidents of
police violence or police killings there
are no longer rebellions against
everyday policing practices against
arrests and the Specter of incarceration
a sign that the status quo has become
accepted in many over police and
underprotected communities however
bitterly and in this sense at least
national and local authorities won the
war on crime
and yet as long as the criminal legal
system proves time and time again to
function as a means to lock people of
color and poor people away for long
prison terms and to sanction police
violence Rebellion remains a possibility
Alan there thank you
[Applause]
let me excuse me let me join the course
in thanking the organizers and our host
of this terrific conference
um
I was speaking to Peter yesterday and he
said oh it's a great group this thing
will run itself
um and I just pointed out to him that
that's the kind of thing that great
hosts whether it be dinner parties or
conferences always say they work
incredibly hard behind the scenes to
make things look like they run
themselves but they most certainly do
not and we are grateful for for all your
work
um let me also take a moment to thank
you all for being here um you know my
students have to sit in rooms and listen
to me so the voluntary the voluntary
um engagement is very deeply appreciated
one of the things that's great about
seeing oh let me turn on my timer
forgive me as an academic I really ought
to turn on a timer unless we be here all
day
uh one of the great things about such a
group Gathering given the title is the
engagement and belief that the public
imagination matters greatly when we
think and talk about mass incarceration
I think that need not be too long
litigated here that is to say the public
imagination and in particular the public
imagination when it comes to race and
crime I think is deeply important or one
might say when it comes to race at all
so from black princes to Black
princesses whether it be the Black
Panther or The Little Mermaid to secular
Kings like the Obamas it is striking to
see how much images of Blackness in the
public media stir instant passion anger
and upset and I think this is no more uh
in no place more powerful than when it
comes to the way in which race and crime
are linked so my core idea starts where
many of you have already known and where
many of my interlocutors on this panel
in particular
um to the two people on our ends three
people people
have engaged with for years that is the
by now well-known idea that one of the
problems in in our American imagination
is the fusing of criminality and race
that is in the very idea that a black
man is presumptively Criminal
that work has been so deeply explored I
actually don't want to litigate much
here um for those who are more
interested or nearer to that idea I'm
happy to recommend what are now
countless uh really thoughtful pieces on
it
what I want to instead speak about
is the idea that how violence is visited
on black men is in connection to black
men being presumptively criminal
considered a form of policing and that's
true whether it be by public or private
individuals that is to say the most
provocative way I put it is that
embedded in so much of white history is
a kind of innate view of white privilege
as innate deputizing so this is a set of
ideas that I've been working on for a
while and indeed I'll have to say the
word deputizing came to me recently at a
conference actually that we were sharing
um and and I hoped that it cap indeed
one of the things I want to test with
you is whether it captures the idea
about which I about which I'm trying uh
the idea I'm trying to pin down
so what do I mean deputizing here is
meant to specify a form of policing and
that is to say deputization highlights a
particular relationship between policing
and violence here unlike Tracy meer's
work which recently has started
exploring the wider use of our term
policing for those of you in in the law
schools here or elsewhere the term
police power is a deep and long historic
legal term with the broadest of uses
that is to say it is as much part of the
police powers of New Haven that they
have zoning laws as it is that they have
actual police officers
but it is also true that that same
breath refracts through our moral and
colloquial thinking as well so we might
talk about policing each other in the
way we behave I believe you know one
might say I police my children it is as
far as we know my main job
um we might say we police each other's
language things like that
um and I don't want to deny that
policing itself that is who is allowed
to police who
instantly invites hierarchy so for
example if Tracy Mears and I are having
a fight over whether or not
um I should have cited some scholar
right whether we're policing academic
Norms it is going to be contested
whether or not a student can suddenly
pipe up and say Professor Yankee you
should have dot dot dot one might say no
no Professor Meers and I are having that
debate that is to say there's hierarchy
and policing that is understood but what
I want to do is focus on policing in a
more specific way that is to say
policing is not just about Norms but in
this case I want to talk about policing
as a form of Justified deployment of
Norm guarding and sanctioning
fair enough
but that when I speak about policing and
deputization
I'm arguing that violence and policing
are in this sense deeply connected right
so I'm not just talking about the way we
might please each other in our normal
everyday Behavior deputizations by the
way we police each other through
violence
and because violence is especially
Salient deputization the argument goes
has its own expression so instead I want
to preserve the salience of potential
violence but I also want to disconnect
it from formally authorized uh policing
by the state and that's what I mean by
deputization
so so far everybody with me
so deputization in this sense has
existed for a long long time for those
of you who are policing Scholars uh
actually better yet for those who are
not policing Scholars uh it's always
hard for us to remember that policing is
actually kind of a new phenomenon that
is modern policing is only I don't know
160 years or something like this
1867. so where that's peels London right
so
1840 here here yeah
I should do the math you get the idea
um one of the reasons I bring this up
actually is when I teach philosophy 101
one of the when when I rarely get to
teach philosophy 101 one of the
interesting things about philosophy is
that a bunch of things we teach students
are so deeply captured in our moments
right so we say things like
I don't know let me give you a silly
example
the sign of a just an authorized state
power is Monopoly over its borders right
you would go back 200 years ago that
would have been a fanciful idea the
state just didn't have the power I mean
they were just weren't the technologies
that we have now that you could so too
with policing when we talk about the
fact that it Justified say it has police
it's actually quite stunning for us to
remember that police were quite a modern
invention why do I say this the point is
policing if you go back only a century
and a half ago was often done by what we
call human cry that is the Justified
Constable right the police officer would
if somebody was the official idea was if
somebody was a felon caught in the act
of a felon could ride could raise you
and cry and that would just be simply to
say to all law-abiding citizens you are
now deputies come with me and let's
capture this felon right so deputization
is a quite powerful way in which
policing has always has always
um occurred so too obviously has its its
links in Jim Crow South where white
people could be deputized at any time in
order to enforce the law and violence
against uh against Negroes especially
escaped slaves before the Jim Crow
period and unruly Negroes afterwards
more importantly I want to point out
that deputization was about that feeling
continuing through our history the
license that white people had to feel it
got to feel about their ability to
enforce violence both formal and
informal to keep black people in place
and that's true again and again even in
less formal ways in large swaths of the
country so I'm thinking for example
during natural disasters in times of
threat when many white communities
simply armed themselves to police police
areas with a firm understanding that
their activities were not illegal
vigilantism but something like
deputization
here then this of course was often done
with the tacit approval of former police
right
but here then is why I want to make the
claim that deputization is important
this is a difference between a kind of
mindset about deputization and the kind
of mindset about ordinary violence right
that is to say deputization is the idea
that one is not just justified in using
violence but that one is authorized that
is to say one is so to speak made an arm
of the state when one does this so the
examples of course are countless but
think of George Zimmerman who very much
deputized himself as a one-man
neighborhood watch think of Ahmad
arbory's Killers who are complicated in
that they were former police officers
but when they see a black man jogging
through the neighborhood they simply
raise you and cry they call their friend
they jump in there they jump in a truck
and decide they're going to capture a
mod Aubry and they experience at least
in their reporting his resistance to
their asking him to stop as his
resistance to their authorized power
right that's a very different kind of
thing than if you and I engage in
violence against each other to which
I'll respond later to which I'll return
later so too Kyle Rittenhouse sees
protesters in Philadelphia and he goes
and gets a long gun and decides that
he's going to join in his imagination
not by the way entirely unfounded
numbers of people who are simply going
to impose order on their community
Through arms and if less fatally
um if less fatally uh Mark and Patricia
mcclonsky who are famous for having
pointed guns at protesters marching by
their home again because they felt they
were authorized too so what do I want to
say about deputization
two points one is that in this sense
deputization is an innate part of our
white culture right it is the power to
think of yourself as authorized to
dispense violence as against black
people not in a way that does wrong but
in a way that makes you an arm of the
state and I want to say that this of
course doesn't mean that violence itself
is a New Concept that would be absurd
right but deputization is a powerful
concept right if Zachary and I are
engaged in violence against each other
we understand ourselves to be engaged in
extra legal behavior and perhaps even
illegal behavior of course they're
communities where this is more
complicated I want to make sure that's
clear there are communities where the
state is sufficiently failing that
people have long thought of their
violence as authorized by the state the
mafia would be the most obvious example
right akosa Nostra meant this thing of
ours the state was insufficiently
protective so we will authorize
ourselves but it is quite something to
think of yourself as latently empowered
to do that everywhere at any time that
is to say rather than my thinking that
when I hit Zach I'm doing something
wrong or something to be punished or
that he and I are just even dispensing
cruelty against each other to think that
when I hit Zach I'm authorized by the
state that his resistance is resistance
to not my just justify power it's not
self-defense it's policing it's
authorized policing and that
that my claim is is a powerful kind of
thinking that black people have not had
access to and that changes white lie
that changes black lives that that is to
say that black people live in a world
Often by the way as an aside I will say
even as I get passionate about this I
dislike speaking so broadly
it is obvious that people have different
experiences different places in the
hierarchy of power and wealth I don't
mean to Ally that but what is true is
that black people are aware that they
live in a world where it's not just that
violence can be visited on them that's
true of everybody but that violence can
be visited on them by people who feel
themselves authorized to do so
right I usually actually don't like to
be very personal I think there's a kind
of
worry that black Scholars are asked to
trade personality for credibility
but I will in one moment just point out
when my boys touch other people's cars
I am frightened and my boys are children
I am frightened because they will not
always be children and it is not that
people will respond to them wrongly I.E
don't touch my car I'm angry it's that
people will feel authorized to visit
violence on them because they are
presumptively criminal that is the power
of deputization that is different than
the power of violence right
that was not in my papers okay
the question with which I want to end is
this
recently well one question I wanted one
question which I want to ask is
well okay one meta question I want to
ask is does the idea of deputization add
anything to the idea of black people is
presumptively Criminal and simple sort
of is This simply racist violence as
such or does the idea of deputization
actually change the way we can think
about this that's a kind of first order
question but setting that aside the
other questions are oh my timers didn't
beat
then I really conclude setting aside
what I want to say is
um I've recently been working on
writings with Keith Humphries at
Stanford on the changing demographics of
of mass incarceration in particular as
many of you know we're in a particular
moment of kind of Left Right convergence
on uh decarceration and that has meant
that the percentage of black prisoners
is dropping relative to the percentage
of white prisoners indeed dropping
faster part of this is kind of feature
not bug I.E when you use your criminal
law system to imprison black people if
you affect your criminal law system
you'll free black people at a faster
rate
um what I want to think about is whether
or not that has an effect of undermining
or destabilizing the image of blacks as
presumptively criminal and whether that
itself has the ability to undermine this
white innate power of deputization the
ability of white people to police black
people through violence what I also want
to know is can if this historical image
of the black criminal can be combated to
drain the idea of legitimization Nation
what happens to the idea of deputization
so for example there is suggestive work
currently on for felony murder which I
will not explain
um but the way felony murder turns out
is often used to punish people
disproportionately it is often used
itself not just disproportionately their
crime but it's also often used in vastly
racially disproportionate ways right so
black people are are prosecuted for
felony murder on in crimes that white
people would not be prosecuted uh for
interesting work has been recently done
where audit Studies have been done
trying to sort out white names black
names and Hispanic names to see what
potential jurors would do and
interestingly while white jurors were
punished less under felony murder
statutes black jurors actually weren't
punished that much more when jurors were
made alert that these were black jurors
that is to say they may be guarding
themselves in this new era
um of thinking about race and mass
incarceration
but Hispanic jurors were punished vastly
out of disproportion so the worry is can
we undermine racial thinking about crime
sufficient to undermine deputization or
the worry might be do we simply push and
hide it into other spaces where our
guards aren't up and these are the ideas
that I'm starting to wrestle with I will
stop there
[Applause]
I'm going to sit I think
I think it works does it work it was
now I've got two take them both
I'll take Echoes I know Echoes worked
uh
and I would like to Echo echo's thoughts
about thanking everybody and thanking
you for being here can you hear me all
right
okay
try to be a little louder I'm uh I'm
very interested in what Echo just said
about uh deputization the word
deputization
and I think one of the things you asked
is if
feedback was positive or negative about
the word and I think it's a very it's a
very uh potent one-word way to suggest a
lot of things that we're talking about
today
and I want to kind of go from there to
loop back to some of the things we were
talking about in the first session which
had to do I think with the imagination
of the way incarcerated people are
imagined and in particular what fiction
uh has to say about that
and if we think about some of what Echo
just talked about I think we're talking
about something that Bernard was talking
about earlier which is the way that
everything becomes fiction if you look
at it
clearly the the idea of deputizing
yourself
and viewing someone else who is a fellow
citizen is someone who are you who you
are in charge of is an act of
imagination it's a negative act of
imagination but it's an act of
imagination
so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
fiction which is what I
do
but I'm going to start by
uh well I'll just read my presentation
is what I think I don't think
all right uh my friend the Loyola
University sociologist Marcus condikar
recently launched a website called the
visiting room
the visiting room compiles videotape
interviews he's done over the course of
five years with men serving life at
Angola prison in Louisiana
each of the videos is vividly unique and
intimate
when I posted the sites link on my
Facebook page one of my friends
responded
I just started looking at things but
anyway interactions would see how
basically label and human these men are
another possibility of parole that's
insane that's evil
it's likely that some of my other
friends who saw my opposed had
first-hand experience of prison
and so I would not be surprised by the
men's stories
should not be surprising anyway but for
many people presence of purely imaginary
space a kind of Darkness covered ideas
and images
I was a marvelous and we've been
interested for a long time in the
question what can fiction possibly do to
address this problem of
misrepresentation
we're a long way from Uncle Tom's Cabin
or together as a Sportsman's sketches
to British slavery and serfdom
fiction is no longer in a position to
shift public policy
perhaps what we can still do then was at
least attempt to create better images in
the way of the visiting room
foreign
[Music]
of his deceased partner in a prison that
is like angle in Louisiana
has a life sentence but has received a
favorable recommendation
and has a chance of getting aired in a
year and a half so he's in this sort of
a limbo
before the visit to the prison
Christopher bed was attacked by one of
his neighbors just as he was planning to
leave the United States from Mexico
he's a painter he gets assaulted by this
this kid who happens to slashes eye
which is an important part of the body
if you're a painter
all right I'll just read a little bit
now
Jesse said it by himself at a table by
the world
t-shirt of a convict as he always said
not the street clothes he lived in the
war
they wasn't even sure of his head first
I'd signaled this uncertainty
[Music]
got distorted by the climate of where he
lived
his old-fashioned solicitude which meant
he wasn't just asking he'd considered
the risks of the world and was glad I'd
made it safely
a couple of days in Texas a state I'd
never seen
and he told me the state of Texas
I was brought to mind the life he wanted
to live when he got out of here
a pickup truck football on TV hunting
and fishing on the weekend a family
maybe for more than that
he pushed his chair closer to mine and
said he wanted to look into the herald
eye
[Music]
there are six muscles in the amendment
he said just in the lit itself not the
eye which had its own very complicated
musculature
when you blinked the six muscles of each
iron kicked into actions simultaneously
flesh 12 reflexes fired muscle tissue
nerve tissue microscopic tissue
the blade was like a backhoe coming
through all that delicate tissue he said
all the way down to the level of the
synapses
it's amazing that healed I said
he moved his chair back to the opposite
side of the table
in the country now he said so the house
quit the job
I should have left a long time ago I
said it's easy to see it now it would
have seemed ridiculous a few years ago
I went over to the both out in the hole
to order some food Jesse got a double
cheeseburger
a man with a sandwich that dropped
around his fingers and was hard to eat
I've got a fish sandwich that was
similar
Taste of the food the difficulty of
eating it the salinity of where we were
the fact that I'd paid we were both
trying not to think all these thoughts
and both failing thinking and eating in
the silos of ourselves
from high school he finally told me a
woman he hadn't seen or heard from in
more than 20 years before she contacted
him last fall she'd started writing in
letters send emails then talking on the
talking to him on the phone and coming
for visits
I knew from conversations we'd had in
the past that people react people
actually had sex in this visiting shed
with its gray linoleum floor and stifled
gray light that made her feel underwater
sometimes they managed to do it right at
the table with their clothes on in front
of the guards
there was a way to push the video games
closer together to create a space that
was hard to be seen in
that wasn't the kind of relationship
Jesse described to me now though she was
solid he said down to earth
she could talk to him about the most
boring things the people she worked with
how none of the stores carried her kind
of cigarettes anymore some lipstick she
found that tasted like cake and he would
listen intently
when you compared it to how they fought
he said it was like the sweet spot
most of his life consisted of sleep work
call eating sleep listening to her talk
about some argument with her sister
finding a way to take her side and argue
for it sincerely it was like getting
high
she put money on his commissary and paid
for his cell phone
that was how they talked and texted and
even flirted with each other in public
on Facebook
you know that the [ __ ] she was living
with wasn't listening to her he said all
that daily life [ __ ] if he was honest
about it he admitted he probably
wouldn't listen to it either if he was
the other man
he knew this but he couldn't really
believe it because he was here not there
it started to turn into this whole movie
in his head Jesse and Antonia like he
could hear the [ __ ] soundtrack
I worried about the Contraband cell
phone but didn't say anything
the institution had special tablet
computers that enabled you to check your
prison email and download music files
which cost more than ordinary ones and I
had bought Jesse one of these players
and funded it every once in a while
but now this seemed quaint inadequate he
was having a love affair with a real
woman who wanted him to have a phone and
who Jesse told me got angry if he didn't
stay in touch with it
he said the relationship was almost as
much as about arguing and strife as it
was about happiness they were drawn to
each other but I always forgot they
tended to argue and look for ways to
hurt each other
they must both get off on it he said
laughing
he told her she had to leave the other
man it was untenable
he was going to cut it off with her she
didn't get her own apartment but
actually he was just like that other man
he said all threats and no follow
through
masochism he said shaking his head
is that what this is with me and her
I think it's just ordinary drama I said
I had that kind of feeling with your
sister sometimes with Anna now it's
different I said different movie he said
different soundtrack
when I tried to imagine his daily life I
would see gray dark hours or Lord
violent ones I'm sorry when I used to
try to imagine his daily life I would
see gray dark hours or lured violent
ones instead of the textures and Hues
his eyes actually saw
I still couldn't see what he saw I knew
that
his Equanimity was something I could
never fathom
okay I'll leave that's it for the
fiction part I promise you
um okay to go back to my friend's
comment on Facebook men serving life in
prison are basically normal and human my
Facebook friend said
fiction tries to enliven statements like
that through mundane trivial details to
can transform abstractions like normal
and human into failed realities
the anatomy of the eye the messiness of
the cheeseburger the Contraband cell
phone
like any art form fiction has the
potential to organize the world's
infinite chaos of particles into a
pattern
though because Fiction's medium is
language it always suggests meaning or
at least the possibility of meaning
this is what the Jewish tradition calls
tikkun Olam or reconfiguring or
repairing the world
my character Jesse contains particles of
people I know or have met but he is
mostly imaginary a figment that I hope
is convincing and not a kind of delivery
vehicle for themes and ideas
when I heard the topic for this session
the image of the prison and the public
mind my first thought
was that that image is usually distorted
or false but I was forgetting a part of
the public for whom prison is not an
image but a first-hand reality
perhaps what a novel can do is at least
connect these two publics in a single
story
I'm going to try to flesh out another
empty abstraction now which is that
prison
that place of violence has also been
shown to me to be a Sacred Space like
all other spaces
a little tiny bit more of fiction it'll
be paying for pain-free I think
this is an email Jesse writes to
Christopher Bell later in the book
I understand why you would want to go to
Mexico he wrote It's Trump time by the
way this book takes place
when you go there to stay it got me
thinking about how when I got out of
here I'll face a totally different world
when I first came to prison there were
no cell phones no Facebook never even
any internet
guys come out of this place and can't
figure out how to buy a toothbrush I'm
told there's too many choices or we have
to order it online
a foreign country is what I'm talking
about like you in Mexico
I'm going to try to keep one foot in and
one foot out you know what I'm saying to
not forget where I came from
it's like when I got to the end of the
book of Exodus in the Bible and there's
a lot of drama going on
Moses brings down the Ten Commandments
they're about to cross over into the
promised land enemy territory
it's really a war is about to set off
and then they stop everything right
there and there's maybe five chapters
just telling you how they built the
Tabernacle this movable temple with the
ark inside it
what kind of architecture there was what
kind of columns they used the different
stones and the types of wood the
ornamentation they tell you exactly how
much gold and silver and bronze they use
to build the gates and the doors and the
hinges and the altar
part of the ornamentation was Badger
skins and RAM skins they dyed red
I remembered all this because I could
really see it they're trying to paint a
picture make you sit with it for a long
time before the story moves forward take
it in
the temple is movable
they're going to take it with them to
the promised land but what they don't
realize is that they're already in the
promised land the actual arrival is just
a matter of time
the whole book of Exodus just ends with
this long description of the Temple
this was how it looked the end
and I was like what the [ __ ] and then I
realized why they did it that way
it's because it's not about some
specific piece of land it's about this
other space that is everywhere
and I'm going to leave it there I want
to just say one thing now I have a
friend who published a book
about a year and a half ago now his name
is Qantas Qantas Conquest whose novel is
called this life
contest has a life sentence in Angola is
still in there and any of you who are
interested in hearing what fiction
sounds like written from
the pen of someone who is in prison I
really recommend that book it's it's a
it's kind of a masterpiece I really
admire it uh it's called This Life by
quantos Conquest
[Applause]
commentings Tracy all right
um is this working yeah
so I since everyone else has already
thanked the organizers and those of you
for being here I'm going to take the
first opportunity to thank
um the speakers so thank you very much
um you might think that I might be
dreading a little bit what I'm about to
do since I have just heard all of these
for the first time and I now have to say
something
um hopefully interesting maybe uh
profound and helpful to those of you
sitting in the audience think about it
but I'm actually quite joyful about this
task because it was an incredible
uh experience to hear all of you speak
and actually
um having been here for the first
session I'm also going to attempt
to draw some connections between the the
first panel and and and this one so
um here it goes
so Judas starts out by uh talking about
incarceration and visibility and I think
using the term visibility is an
interesting one and the context of the
subject of the conference you know
incarceration and Imagination what role
does visibility play when we are engaged
in the project of imagination and so I
want to use that frame the idea of
visibility contrast it with the concept
of what's not secret which is also
something that Judith said and just sort
of trouble the idea that visibility and
and not secret are equivalent which I
think Judith sort of suggested I'm not
saying that that's what you meant that's
just literally what you said I wrote it
down
um and how the juxtaposition of those
terms helps us to think about the
project of imagination so that's one
frame the second frame is something that
Zachary offered he asked the question
what can fiction do to address
misrepresentation
and that made me think about the
interaction between representation on
the one hand and misrepresentation on
the other in the context of visibility
right I think there what Bernard said in
the last session is his offering or
maybe we'll call it a provocation
that we're all engaged in fiction
what does that have to do with
visibility on the one hand
representation
misrepresentation and then this project
of imagination okay so that's the
overall frame I'm going to take each
presentation in turn hopefully still
being on under 10.
um so Elizabeth starts out with this
idea of you know she talks about the
image of the prison in the public mind
in the context of rebellion and then the
process of of rebellions that she
describes I think would immediately
cause us to think about what are we
talking about when we say public
obviously there are lots of publics I
mean for Elizabeth's subjects she's I
think talking about the public parts of
the public involved in Rebellion itself
and and these and and these kids and one
of the things that immediately came to
mind and listening to the details that
Elizabeth was offering was a connection
between
um the first session and in particular
Joy's comments about fugitive fugitivity
and marinage
um where you know Elizabeth gives us
this incredibly Vivid picture of
teenagers I don't even want to call them
teenagers I mean as a 13 year old a
teenager like as a child right they're
babies
um who are at in her terms sacrificing
their own Freedom
um against the specter for them of of in
prison so that there they have an
imaginary of of what this is you know is
it visible to them like what is it that
they see you know to borrow another uh
phrase that Zachary offered is is this a
movie in their head or you know is is
something else happening but anyway
there's what their their actual action
um of sacrificing their freedom and
um I'm thinking about that next to the
prison narratives that Joy was talking
about that are excluded these narratives
of fugitivity so one question for you is
sort of how do we think about the these
kids you know engaged in that act
in a context where
in incarceration people are doing
is it Opposite I don't even know how to
think about you know fugitivity next to
what they are doing but I would like
invite you to to think about that and
talk about that
um the next thing that Elizabeth talks
about in in her uh in her comment was
you know she's talking about maybe their
imagination is about mass incarceration
and then you tell a story about removal
of many young people from neighborhoods
and places where and I'm again quoting
you it's well maybe this is my
interpretation of it removing and
quelling activism right this activism
these rebellions are quite visible I
mean visible in the regular normal
everyday way we think of visibility it's
not an imagination right we we see it
and and
if this quelling is removing people and
putting them in prison prison that
um Judith tells us is not Secret
right but it's also not visible
um certainly not in the same way that
that rebellions are I think there's a
way in which the incarceration even if
people are still engaged in activism
it's obscuring the nature of the
activism I wonder if that's the link to
fugitivity I don't know but maybe that's
a jumping off place
um
and then the final thing that's I want
to say in connection with the the first
panel is that there's a way in which the
mass Aggregates
they are not Secret
not visible but to make visible and
legible
that kind of activity might require some
kind of individuation
which you know those of us on this panel
were invited by Zachary to go to the
website that he spoke about which was
incredibly compelling for me to read
these listen to these individual stories
and then I sat through the first panel
and then I thought huh am I supposed to
think about these individual stories in
the same way as compelling in the same
way given you know the comments that
Caleb offered I'm just not sure so you
know
question in there somewhere okay for
Echo he is giving us
um this incredibly evocative concept of
deputization and I wish I could remember
the name of the
um the philosophy student at off at
Harvard who actually brought this up at
this at this conference conference that
Echo and I were at it was really
um it was really jarring and and also
generative
um I think it's a really helpful
um concept but here's a thing to think
about right so we have
um you you note the Hue and cry
which creates a concept of deputization
which is in a sense pre-state or
pre-modern state as we understand it
right it's it's not Regulatory and and
here I'm connecting with the talk that I
just gave and it certainly
um
pre-regulated police power in the U.S as
as we think about it
um maybe not the Continental version
so we go from deputization to you know
here's a timeline State creation we're
going to call the beginning of the
modern state to use Bill Novak's
formulation sort of the new deal so now
we're in the like the 1930s 1940s you
say well of course it's not that
deputization goes away it just becomes
less visible so there's that frame again
right it's that it's not secret or is it
secret how do we think about its
visibility and to the extent that it is
visible today of course it's not the Hue
and cry so much as it's do I want to
call it an implicit deputization so
um you know permit Patty you know
um by calling on the police you know to
police activity of of folks you know the
the black Minister who is very kindly
watering his neighbor's Garden when The
Neighbor is on
um vacation and when police are called
in that case the person calling the
police is that an implicit deputization
that fits in with the your model or does
that is that pushing your concept too
far because I think one answer you might
have as well I'm actually talking about
their own use of violence and not
calling upon the state but then how do
we think about that line again I think
the ways in which we think about line
depends on ideas of visibility and and
how we think about what visibility means
is it just something that we know or is
it something that we need to see is it
the movie in our mind all right and then
for you Zachary
um
what I thought was fascinating
about the fiction you shared
was
um how Vivid the quotidian was so right
you know the uh I just became a
pescetarian and and I'm hungry so when
you started talking about the fish
sandwich I was like you know where's
that fish sandwich I could kind of smell
it actually
um uh you know and so that starts to
bring in other senses so when we're
talking about visibility are we talking
about something that we see are we
talking about other senses which brought
to mind for me
um this book I just picked up I haven't
read it yet but um it's by a journalist
whose name is Ed young and it's
something like the men's World of animal
senses
um and
um so he talks about all of the things
that humans Miss because we can't see UV
light and you know our hearing is not as
Keen as my puppies and they talks about
these um these insects and plants that
vibrate on plant leaves and if you could
actually translate it into sound you
could actually hear a symphony but you
know all the little bugs I guess are
feeling in their feet or something I
don't know I don't know exactly how it
works like I said haven't finished the
book yet but you know the question is
when we're trying to come to conclusions
about the role of visibility and
Imagination would you maybe make an
argument that what fiction does in you
know the Vivid quotidian is to allow us
to sort of push the boundaries of our
senses and then that's what's really
required for imagination and if so then
you know visibility just to start to
come back to where I began might not be
the word we want to use
that's it thanks
[Applause]
we have exchanges among ourselves but we
want to start by inviting any comments
or questions from the Caleb we'll start
with you and please introduce yourself
and I think you need to scream a little
bit oh microphones are coming to you so
just reintroduce yourself as well hi
Caleb Smith
um thanks for this
really uh Illuminating panel I really
appreciate it
um
I had I wanted to pick up Tracy on
something you said about I you and I can
pick up the individuation thing but um
really about echo's uh paper and the
concept of deputization which I found
really
valuable
um and it's I do think this is one of
the places where intellectual work can
have some leverage actually is by
introducing Concepts that then just get
picked up and they condense a lot of
thinking and they have a life in the
culture and they allow people to name
phenomena but like Tracy my specific
question was about whether the state is
the authorizer of deputization
um if I think about January 6th I think
about the state as a threat to the
deputy the felt deputization of the
people there
um if I think about what people think
Second Amendment is protecting them from
it's from state encroachment on their
deputized power to do the kinds of
things that you're describing
so I wondered
if
um and and I think that's I do think
there are moments of quite clear State
authorization if you see something say
something
is you know as an example
but I wonder if something like if to me
it seems like in some of the cases
you're talking about it's something like
the nation
and a kind of white nationalism that's
authorizing the deputization which can
actually then be turned against the
state as being secular Multicultural
limiting on this kind of power
um so I'm just uh
I I also do think there's a kind of
expectation of exoneration you know
that's built into it so that so fair but
I'm asking I just wanted to think about
um whether there's even a certain kind
of more uh mystical or fascistic uh
deputizing Power at work here
um than the state as that is up because
there's obviously a lot of
you know white nationalist anti-state
sentiment of its own type
so thank you for the question Caleb
thank you for the question
um
so this is I mean as many of you know
this is actually the really great moment
when you have an idea you think it has
real shape but you don't quite know it
yet because after this after a year or
so of Defending an idea you're just sort
of like trying to survive right so this
is fun because I really don't know the
answer to your questions I'm you know in
a way that perhaps is insufficiently
protective just thinking with you all
but here are a couple of thoughts I do
have
um so I take your question as of a piece
with Tracy's when does the ability to
cast your hand right wave power at
people
become deputization when after all it
can be calling the police to to do
something that the police you know to
enforce essentially your social norms I
I don't want this person barbecuing or
or is it as I was trying to I think
encircle when you feel authorized to use
force yourself
so I I'm gonna just so that I don't go
on and on I'm going to use three
examples say they're on a spectrum but
say I want deputization to pick out a
particular end of the spectrum so one
example is self-defense right people
feel authorized to use self-defense and
use violence in self-defense and it's a
powerful authorization indeed when you
teach self-defense and criminal law one
of the really interesting things is it's
hard to give a particular justification
of self-defense but nobody's willing to
give it up it's one of the most deeply
felt moral claims that I can use
violence to protect myself is against
you but I don't think that's
deputization people feel that as a kind
of natural right and that's interesting
to me
I said three examples I'm gonna use four
because you gave me one the second
amendment I think is something like that
it is a felt kind of natural right that
some people at least in the American
psyche in very few other places and I
don't I think you're right it is not
you know if if you were to tell most
people that self-defense is a state
granted right they'd say no I mean to
the extent they think about it they'd
say no it's a state granted recognition
of some deeper natural right and I think
that people who either deeply are
committed to or fetishized second
amendment think of it something like
that right January 6 is an interesting
counter example because I actually do
think it's an example of deputization
one of the interesting things about the
January 6 rioters is that they resist
the phrase January 6 rioters right
indeed the late breaking news of the
subpoena of the former president is
precisely because the claim is he misled
these people thinking they were
deputized these were not people who said
something's gone wrong with the state
thus I'm overthrowing it these are
people who it is deeply important then
that they hold on to the claim that
they're Patriots because they were
deputized and my point is that there's
something important about that they
wouldn't hold on to it so dearly if it
weren't important and then lastly I want
to say I think that's the end of the
spectrum I want to get to and people
feel authorized themselves to use their
violence and I want to say it's even
different than self-defense again it's a
spectrum one of the things that's
difficult about many instances of black
or violence on black people is that it's
described as self-defense and we know
that the self-defense is deeply racially
refracted right the the black man
sneezed and thus self-defense but what I
want to say is that's what frightens
people when it comes to racial violence
it's not just that you might be violent
towards me or you might want my wallet
that happens to the world it's that you
feel authorized to do so and that's what
I want to pick out that I think is on
the further end of the spectrum
the question in terms of language is
about the word first of all entitlement
but also I keep thinking gender and
violence against women and the gender of
the interaction as yeah needing to be
engaged as the authority to be violent
against a person in your household
yeah and how that form of entitlement
plays and whether you want to deputizing
may be a subset of an entitlement to
engage
some of which could come from so there's
obviously more we want to probe and
trying to understand the parameters of
the imagery and claim that's really
helpful I I don't want to dominate this
but I would say that's really helpful
because I think
you might think for example that Violent
Men
dispensing violence against women 200
years ago was seen as both entitled and
deputized and now some men still think
it's entitled but I think very few men
think it's deputized very few men would
say I'm actually the state would
authorize the city longer unless we
think of abortion but let's go
and very quickly
um
listening to
Echo talk and then Caleb's response I
just couldn't help but could you read
something
minor
um thinking about deputization I
realized that reading racecraft by
Barbara and Karen Fields was the first
time in my life when somebody explained
to me so clearly what ideology is and if
I have their definition correct ideology
is not something that you memorize and
then repeat it has to be enacted over
and over and over again to do its real
work so I was thinking deputization is
the enactment of ideology over and over
again regardless of the four types you
just cited what it's doing is is
spreading and reproducing itself and
um like I was I'm sorry I live in Los
Angeles but you know the president of
our city council Mary Martinez said on
tape which was reproduced on Reddit that
her fellow councilman Mike bonin's I'm
sorry it's very disturbing his adopted
black son she said if she needed to be
able to take him around the corner and
beat his ass this is we're talking about
a two-year-old child this I'm sorry this
is very very disturbing but it is I
think the reproduction of ideology in
herself deputization casually in that
moment and so she's even calling upon an
imaginary space where people are
continuing to do this kind of work I
think maybe in a way does it relate to
Elizabeth hinton's wonderful piece about
the protest movement are we also ha like
why do we have to go out on the streets
over and over and over again every time
we witness State sanctioned violence is
it also our work to reproduce a counter
ideology
I've obviously I want to learn a little
bit but I just first of all thank you
for that I just want to add one last
small list of Corrections is that Jacob
his son is actually uh eight now and I
know this because Mike and Sean are
actually friends of mine and oh why they
keep saying that he was two or three
years old and this was a year ago so
they're friends of mine actually and so
I've had to live I mean I don't pretend
it's but you know it's been painful to
be in touch with them
um I remember when they adopted Jacob
and I played with Jacob in their
backyard and that kid is loved sorry
thank you um for the question I think in
some ways it relates to the points that
um Tracy was making about fugitivity
unfortunately I was unable to hear
Professor James's uh remarks but um he
couldn't make it to the the morning
panel but I think you know the example
of the kids I mean in in this right they
literally
um allowed the kids in Baltimore
um allowed the suspects who were being
arrested said to become fugitives right
I mean I think
you know and that's in some ways the
point that I ended on as long as
um we have violence sanctioned by the
state the state has a monopoly on
violence and with that the the
people are white people in particular
are deputized to enact
um violence and I think you know in
response to
um Caleb's point and also thinking about
deputization in January 6th
you know it it's it's about white
supremacy white supremacist ideology
that in that that is slippery in terms
of its ties to the state
um so you know when Donald Trump
um you know tells people come to the
Capitol it's going to be Wild Storm the
capital that's that's that sanctioned
white supremacist violence which is
always has always been part of the um
American state but as long as
um you know we we're continuing to live
in this where where some groups of
people are fugitives some groups of
people are captive
um
than than it is you know the
responsibility
um and and a natural response of those
conditions um to contest them I mean one
of the big things I didn't get into it
in this talk but you know of the the
book um American fire from which I draw
in this work is that violence
precipitates violence it's a cycle of
violence of state-sanctioned violence
and then Community violence
um Insurgency encounter Insurgency that
we've been
stuck in
um
because of our economic systems our our
ideologies Etc
we started a couple minutes late so I'm
going to invade lunch a teeny bit uh and
uh invite and I think the way to do it
is there are a few hands up so we're
gonna take the hands that are up and
listen to you and then everybody will
get their closing comments in
relationship to you and otherwise and
the people with microphones are better
at me than running around please
introduce yourselves but please grab the
put your hand up high uh and so we can
grab all your comments and then uh have
a response go ahead start hi um my name
is Rich vijatt I'm with the prison
education program at NYU and um I want
to say thank you for this entire day
really um
I am one of the coordinators there I do
re-entry work
and I'm also a poet and indeed I'm a
poet that is steeped in a lot of those
Traditions that came out of those uh
rebellions that were spoken of so
eloquently
um during the 60s and 70s and as such
our literature Eureka literature Black
Arts Movement black nationalism a lot of
that stuff is informed by writers who
were formerly incarcerated
and one thing I haven't heard yet unless
I missed it is the literary imagination
from that liminal space right from the
space that is not incarcerated but who
is kind of bringing the experience of
trauma and I do social work right so
trauma is always part of that the
experience of trauma and the time lost
um into a world that has in in large
part moved on or moved away or moved in
different directions so I'm curious in
any of your readings if you've come
across and we're going to hear from
formerly incarcerated writers later
which is awesome
but my question to you is about
um the theory behind it and some of the
thinking that maybe some folks have put
on paper around writing from that space
and I'm curious if any of your readings
you've come across and and this could
this could mean centuries ago I don't I
don't know uh of writers who are talking
about that process
um and I wonder if there might be uh a
recommendation for a reading or two for
someone who is has students who are
writing from there
hi my name is sonali chakravarti I'm
from Wesleyan University and my research
is about juries which are a very
specific type of public whose
imagination of prisons and of defendants
carries a lot of weight um and I'm
curious if the panelists feel that there
might be any movement in the way um
jurors in this country understand
um the different aspects of this story
um and in addition to there's a huge
need to have more racially diverse
stories um certainly but I'm just also
curious if you see the possibilities of
a change um in the in the imagination of
jurors
uh I think there were a couple other
hands over here sorry go ahead yes
please will be Geographic are you sure
no please please
uh so mine was kind of related to the
and thank you Professor hiten but
um I'm Nasir
um yeah undergrad
so I guess my question I was It was kind
of thinking with the January 6th riots
so I remember the
um I was actually my APUSH class and we
were like watching it live and we saw
like the the gals with um from Mike
Pence and I was thinking too they um the
the same people who are motivated on
that day had the Gallows for Obama and
um actually putting like dolls with him
being hung and I guess
you you refer to like him as a a black
and a secular King I thought that was
interesting and like
I guess
I'm just trying to think out loud here
so it was Obama he was like in Indonesia
he was in going to the mother says
Islamic schools he's Kenyan he has a
Muslim middle name and he's the head of
a white government
and that must have caused confusion for
people who were you know you know as you
were saying being Sanctified to use this
violence and I guess maybe they felt
betrayed
buy mic pants and that he deserved that
Mike Pence deserved the same punishment
as someone who was black but Obama might
not be like African-American he's like
uh he's like a he's like an Eastern
black you know and I want to see how
that confusion led to the same you know
result of anger and Punishment through
such a very American violent way of
punishment which is the lynching so that
was what I was wondering
uh there there were hands from the back
at least two or one I can't I think
there's two so thank you
um for everything a little bit it's a
little okay you can hear me now so
thanks to the panel who doesn't have
perfect Acoustics okay
um so I was wondering if you could say
more about the distinction between
self-defense and violence I know
seminarians who created non-profits in
New York City around domestic violence
intimate violence and the statement
along with some Buddhist is you can use
Force against violence but force is not
a synonym
for violence so then self-defense has
this distinct category
I think there's one more hand there yes
please hi uh Andrew Clark from UConn
um I'm interested in the concept of
punishment
um and Judith in your initial slides
when you talked about prison there's a
lot of punishment that's in there and
then the idea uh Elizabeth that you
talked about The Crucible period and the
hyper incarceration which infused
punishment even more into the karsh
rural space
um
and and then the idea of deputizing and
who gets deputized to uh punish within
prison and then going to the the fiction
Narrative of how can we change this and
when we're looking at other countries
that don't view uh prison as a
punishment scheme but see as the taking
away of Liberty as punishment and the
role of a prison guard or correction
system is actually Rehabilitation is
there a way to change that narrative
from
um
someone that's been deputized to punish
to be deputized to actually help
everybody whether intersecting with
these questions or the exchange among
the panels if we go back this way
I don't have any answers you know those
questions
I don't know I have to think about it
more can okay okay Zachary
um
I know there's a lot out there so
there's a lot of lacks yeah I I think
pursue the aphrosu uh
I think we've been talking a lot about
language actually I think we've been
talking about
oh I can't remember what Joy's point was
just now about distinguishing violence
and forth uh using the word deputization
to pinpoint a number of things with one
word
and I think what I'd like to say about
that is just it's pretty simple
uh that I think that we live in a
culture in which we're bombarded with
images images
and I think
language is one way to
resist that and to get past that
um and I think
you know you said something interesting
about senses in general and I was just
reading
this book about uh
Jewish mysticism and and uh
it's talking about how
there's a difference between wisdom and
understanding and that wisdom is a flash
of of
knowledge it's
God is sending some sort of energy that
gives you this flash of knowledge which
is sort of I guess like intuition and
then past that is understanding
which is when you take that flash and
you analyze it and particularize it and
I think that's what and that's
considered a next phase that's a higher
phase than wisdom actually understanding
and I think that's what language is
helping us to do and I think that that's
what this Symposium and things like it
are are useful in doing
I've been given a lot of time so I won't
take too much more on your first off
thank you for your wonderful work
um I don't know a lot about uh people
written inside but Dr James has a set of
anthologies which I just became aware of
so you might want to speak to her or
just Google or buy everything she's
written
also an idea I'm planning on doing so
um I should say professor and Dr James
but um there's been so much offered I
just want to say
um Elizabeth I love this question of the
kids fighting in Baltimore allowing
others to become fugitive sonali you
know how much I appreciate your work on
juries I really want to think about that
I actually think that's a really
important one in the way in which
so when I teach criminal law there are
just a lot of stories about
um the disconnect between jurors and in
particular when the juries are not
racially diverse and now you're starting
to see that change
um you pointed out the um
and something odd about the Rodney King
video
the analog I always make is
if you finally believed your wife after
she complained for years about her boss
because you saw the video your
relationship would have both taken a
step forward and a step back right
because it's sort of like well I
complained to you since time in memoriam
you had to see the video so I think it's
it's complicated
um on the Obama point I think it's a
great Point thank you for that what I
want to say is something like I think
you can be patriotic without thinking
you're authorized so you can be a
patriot of a lost state for example
there are people who thought they were
fighting for the state that was taken
away from them and they're people who
think they're authorized by the current
state and I want to disentangle that and
likewise I want to disentangle
self-defense versus violence along the
same lines
um I think self-defense comes closer to
the idea of force uh the idea that it's
an innate authorization whereas violence
is more what I'm pointing at
deputization I'll stop there thank you
all for your comments I've been enjoyed
yeah I just this has been a really
um enriching conversation so I want to
thank my fellow panelists once again and
all of you for your really thought for
poking questions I guess just picking up
on the last one in terms of trying to
end maybe on a hopeful note thinking
about what help might look like how we
can reframe some of these things it
picks up on
um my last comment in the sense you know
we we know
um what the solutions are I mean that's
you know the people who felt like they
had no other recourse but to
um enact various uh forms of violence
against the state knew that the solution
was resources into under-resourced
communities and um and jobs and better
schools and a redistribution the Kerner
Commission in 68 says all of this right
and so I mean I think that's why the
questions of this conference are so
interesting because in order to actually
you know bring about the the kind of
form of governance that would be
necessary to do that which is you know
what I think defund is really all about
calling for a different set approach to
governance given that these punitive
strategies have failed to actually keep
communities safe
um how are we going to then you know
move the the public imagination
um
to be able to to not other people to to
de-link
um
people of color black people from ideas
about criminality
um and to make more visible perhaps in
order to raise that awareness
um these underlying problems and the
failed policies so you know in a lot of
ways that's the task
um before us but the imagination is so
key within within that
and thinking what these meanings and
sensory experiences are
um and there's this idea of The
Sovereign whether the deputy is the
quasi-sovereign or The self-understood
Sovereign in the household and the
non-sovereign and the underlying
question is what can we do to each other
in what level of authority and there are
some things that have been debated like
whipping or starving that for some
social orders we take off the table it
doesn't that it isn't happening it's
that we don't say it's authorized when
we disavow that Authority and the
current struggle is what do we disavow
and what do we refund as well as what do
we defund and
um it's been incredibly moving
participating in a conversation with you
all around these incredibly weighty
Topics in a scary time
um I think I'm supposed to announce or
actually better yet well we want to
first of all thank Diane and also I want
to thank
um you've been incredibly logistically
engaged and in terms of when you were
saying things just happen
um things don't just happen they happen
because people work hard at making them
happen so I think we all need to pause
to thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]